Một kênh con sây dức đã sắp xuống đường tại tình xamu sắc con,
vần thủ đô bằng cốc, để chúng ta uto khiến hàng người thêm mạng và hàng người khác bị thương.
Bù việc sây ra tại công trường sây dức, đường có tức trên gau.
Thế ngành từ hiện trường cho thấy cần cầu bị gạy đồ.
Cùng cơ khối về tông lời, dời sma đường, bù kia phần tiện,
phải quay đau tránh khu vực miệng.
Sự go diễn ra chỉ một ngày sau khi một cần cầu khác,
sắp tại tình nha con, rất chà si mà ở đường bắt hay lần.
Dời sống tuyến đường sắp đằng khá thác,
làm một đồn tầu trật bánh khiến bà miệng hay khách chiến mà.
Bù việc cũng làm hàng trục người khác bị thương.
Bù trường, giáo thông thế lần cho biết, một công ty xây dức mạo tế identa liền thái,
để v mềm, có liên quan, tới 2,5 tế nạn này.
Với nghiệp này chưa được ra bình luận về vụ việc mới nhất.
Sông trước đó đã chấp nhận bùi thường cho các bạn nhớ trong vụ sập cần cầu và tổ hoa.
Thủ trường thái lán ăn được tin sẽn bị đó Cung nhận đec.
Các tái nạn lập lại cho khai cần cần chung, sự đồ lột và tăng cường các bạn pháp bảo đã mang toàn trong thích sây dức.
Thái lán cũng đã đầy mặt khi công nhiều sự án khác tâm vi See More Learn.